[موسيقى]
مساء الخير اهلا بكم اله نشره الرابعه من
الرياض التي نقدم من خلالها ابرز اخبار
ملفات السعوديه والخليج وهذه ابرز عناوين
اليوم
روسيا تقول بان حزمه العقوبات الجديده
ستفاقي مشكله الاقتصاديه للاتحاد الاوروبي
وسائل الاعلام ايرانيه تقول بان السلطات
اعتقلت محامي صحافيين كشفا قضيه مقتل
الشاب مساء اميني
وصوله سبعين الف طن من الديزل والمازوت
الى عدن ضمن الدفعه الثانيه من منحه
المشتقات السعوديه
نتناول واياكم في الرابعه كذلك
الداخليه السعوديه تعلن عن ترحيل 11 الف
مخالفه لانظمه الاقامه والعمل خلال اسبوع
المنتخب المغربي يواجه مساء اليوم كرواتيا
في مباراه تحديد المركزين الثالث والرابع
حياكم الله استبعدت الخارجيه الروسيه
اجراء محادثات مباشره بين روسيا واوكرانيا
والوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه بشان
منطقه حمايه لمحطه النوويه ووصف مندوب
روسيا في فيينا ميخائيل اوليانوف اجراء
هذه المحادثات بانها مستحيله في الوقت
الراهن جهه الاخرى قالت الخارجيه الروسيه
ان الاتحاد الاوروبي مصمم على الاضرار
بمصالحه في قطاع الطاقه مؤكده ان
الاجراءات الاوروبيه احاديه الجانب ضد
روسيا جعلت وضع الطاقه في اوروبا باكملها
بما في ذلك البلقان معقده
دشن المستشار الالماني الله بشاط قبل قليل
الاول وحده عائمه للغاز المساله في
المانيا بهدف تجنب النقص والتخلي عن
الشحنات الروسيه التي اوقفتها الحرب في
اوكرانيا لكن التزود بهذه الماده على
الامد القصير مازال غير مؤكد وستقام خمس
محطات عائمه اخرى خلال العام الجاري بعد
اشغال بناء جرت بفضل مليارات اليوروها
التي افرجت عنها الحكومه الالمانيه
اعلنت سلطات المواليه لروسيا في انشاء درع
لحمايه محطه النوويه من الاستهداف وقالت
ان هذا الدرع الذي يصل ارتفاعه الى خمسه
امتار سيحمل محطه نوويه من الشضايا
والعبوه الناسفه وهجمات المسيرات وقال
المتحدث باسم الكرملين في وقت سابق ان
روسيا باقيه على اتصال مع الوكاله الذريه
من اجل انشاء منطقه منزوعه السلاح حول
محطه زبروج
من باريس ينضم الينا الكاتب السياسي
اندريه مهاويل سيد اندريه مرحبا بك معي في
نشره الرابعه من الرياض دعني اولا ابدا من
حزمه العقوبات التي استهدفت روسيا وهي
الحزمه التاسعه استهدفت 200 فرد ومؤسسه
ثلاثه مصاري روسيه همم حاضر لاستثمارات
التعدين ايضا ما هو مستوى تاثير هذه
الحزمه بالنسبه لروسيا تاثير ارتداداتها
كذلك على الاتحاد الاوروبي
مرحبا طبعا هذه العقوبات هي ليست الاولى
كما ذكر فيها الحزمه التاسعه حتى الان هذه
العقوبات لم تؤدي بعد بشكل مباشر الى ليزي
ذراع همم روسيه بالتجاوب مع الطلبات
الاوروبيه او الغربيه بشكل عام لا بل على
العكس امانه تصريحات ايضا لمسؤولين رؤوس
منذ الامس واليوم بان روسيه غير مستعده
للتنازل لماذا اولا لان الروسيه وضعت نظام
خاص بيعمل اجل التداول بكل المواد والسلع
التي يمكن لها ان تصدرها او ان تستوردها
بعض الدول وافقت على التعامل والاقزت
بموضوع الطاقه بالروبن لروسيه ايضا
امتدادات وحلفاء همم يمكن ان يفتح لها لها
اسواق ان كان في ايران او بعض دول امريكا
اللاتينيه او في اسيا
بالمقابل اوروبا تبدو حتى الان هي الاكثر
تضررا لسببين الاول ان نقص الكبير الذي
تعانيه الان الاسواق الاوروبيه خصوصا في
مجال الطاقه وبالتالي فان اوروبا تتعامل
مع هذا الموضوع ايضا من قبيل همم
ارتدادات على الراي العام نعرف ان الدول
الاوروبيه تتاثر بالراي العام وحتى الان
يعني ظهرت بعد بوادر راي العام ولكن يجب
ان ننتظر حوالي الشهر يعني بعد راس السنه
اعياد نهايه هذه السنه دينار مدى تحرك
الراي العام والشارع بالنسبه
في الاعتراض على هذه النقطه سيده سندريلا
لكن على
سيد اندريه على النقيب على النقيب تماما
ان كنت تسمعني سيد همم
ان كنت تسمعني على النقي تماما ارسلفونتر
لاين ذكرت في وقت سابق بان وضع الطاقه في
الدول الاوروبيه هذا الشتاء همم وضع مستقر
استطاعت اوروبا في ان توفر على الاقل
احتياجاتها في هذه المرحله تحدثت بان ربما
المرحله المقبله وهي شتاء 2020 هو همم
يعني ستكون همم سيكون صعبا على الاتحاد
الاوروبي ان لم ااه يعني يفعله اليه لاشر
همم الجماعي للطاقه في هذا التوقيت الان
روسيا تقول بان الوضع متوتر ومعقد في
الطاقه برايك اي ال ال ال الخيارين او اي
تصريحين باقرب لي الحقيقه فيما تعاني
اوروبا اليوم او تمر به
طبعا اوروبا استطاعت بعد تسعه اشهر من
الازمه ان تجد بعض الحلول ولكنها ليست
حلول ولا يمكن لها ان تعالج المشكله
نهائيا او تعود نهائيا عن
[موسيقى]
الموارد الطاقه الروسيه خصوصا بالنسبه
للغاز نعرف ان الدول الاكثر تاثرا كانت
المانيا ولكن في المده الاخيره حصلت
اتفاقات داخليه بين دول اعضاء الاتحاد
الاوروبي بان يتم التبادل فرنسا التي كان
لديها المخزون المخزون الطاقه والغاز كانت
بشكل يعني الان كليا قدمت ايضا بعد همم
الامطار المكعبه بالالف طبعا الى المانيا
ولا الدول الاخرى المشكله الاساسيه انا
كما ذكرت هي بعد راس السنه ليس فقط بسبب
الشتاء الان الناس بدات
تعتاد على فكره ان تكون درجات الحراره في
المنازل مثلا 19 درجه او ان يتم التقنين
في الطاقه وفي بعض الامكنه غير الضروريه
مثل المعامل الليله مثلا او الشوارع
العامه المشكله الاساسيه ستبدا ابتداء من
مطلع السنه وحتى الصيف هناك بعض التقديرات
التي تقول بان اوروبا سوف تكون في حاجه او
بنقص 30 مليار متر مكعب من الغاز ما
اقتراب فصل الصيف المقبل وبالتالي
وبالتالي هل يمكن هذا ان يغير بعض المواقف
الاوروبيه في التعامل مع ازمه همم الطاقه
في التعامل ايضا او التعاطي مع فكره همم
يعني حزم جديده من العقوبات المفروضه على
روسيا انت تدهورت الاوضاع وصلت الى مرحله
يعني لا يمكن تحملها في همم يعني قادم
الايام وبعد طبعا نهايه همم السنه كما
ذكرت
موضوع الطاقه لا يتصل فقط على التدفئه
هناك موضوع الصناعه المصانع والمعامل
الانتاج الصناعي سوف يتاثر في دول اوروبا
الصناعيه حركه النقل سوف تتاثر ايضا لذلك
اوروبا الان تراهن على شيء اساسي من خلال
رفع حجم العقوبات والتسريع بهذه العقوبات
لاعينا اخيرا قبل يومين شملت حوالي 200
شخصيه ومؤسسه روسيه جديده
تامل بان تتمكن من لي ذراع الروسيه
والرئيس الروسي قبل ان تصل الى هذا
الاستحقاق الكبير كما ذكرت مطلع الصيف
وحاجته على 300 مليار متر مكعب اضافي
اوروبا هي المتاثر ولكن القرار النهائي
ليس القرار هو عند الامريكيين الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه هي التي تدير هذه ان
كان على الصعيد الميداني او على الصعيد
الاقتصادي والمالي
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه لم تتاثر كما
هو الحال بالنسبه لاوروبا لان الحرب لا
تجري على ارض ملكيه بل على ارض اوروبيه في
النهايه الموضوع الثاني الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه لديها الاكتفاء موضوع الطاقه
واعت الطاقه التي عرضت بيعها الى اوروبا
لكي من ناحيه النفط او الغاز او غيره هي
تباع باثار اا يعني اربعه اضعاف اما هي
عليه بالنسبه ما هو سعر الطاقه حاليا
وبالتالي يعني يعني هذه الاجراءات احاديه
الجانب او التي همم كما قلت يعني تقودها
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه على المستوى
ربما العسكري او حتى على المستوى
الاقتصادي فيما يخص العقوبات وغيره ايضا
كيف ستعامل اولا معها مسكوب بنسبه لدول
اوروبا اعيد مره اخرى عليك سيد اندريا هل
يمكن ان تتراجع في بعض المواقف اذا كانت
تبعها الولايات المتحده الامريكيه الطاقه
باربعه اضعاف ما كانت تشتريه من روسيا
بيظل وضع اقتصادي اصلا صعب بعد جائعات
كورونا لهذه الدول
على كل حال اوروبا
حتى الاجتماع الاوروبي قبل يومين في
بروكسيل من خلال فرض حزمه عقوبات جديده
اوروبا لا تعول على درجه الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه طالب بانها لديها سياسه
استراتيجيه خاصه هي تعول على اي زراعه
الروسيه المشكله كما ذكرت سوف تكون خلال
السنوات المقبله هناك تقرير لوكاله
الدوليه للطاقه الدوليه تقول بناء الاتحاد
الاوروبي سوف يعاني خلال السنوات الثلاثه
المقبله يعني في تلبيه حاجتها من الطاقه
بشكل قد يضر باقتصاده بشكل مباشر ان كان
على الصعيد التجاره او على الصعيد الصناعي
هذا هو الخوف الحقيقي الذي تسعى اوروبا
لمعالجته كان هناك
رهان اوروبا على ان تكون ربما ايران من
خلال تواصل الى اتفاق معها البديل عن
مصادر الطاقه هذا العمر الان ملف ايران
والملف النووي الاتفاق مع ايراد بعد الدول
الخليجيه لديها الاستعداد وراينا ان هناك
محادثات كثيره وقد الرئيس الف ولكن كل هذا
العمر لا تعوض عن الطاقه الروسيه المصادر
الطاقه الاوروبيه نظرا لقربها ولاسعارها
المنخفضه
رعينا بعض الاصوات كما قال رئيس الفرنسي
خلاله وجودي في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه قبل اسبوعين من خلال دعوته الى
التحم مطالب الروسيه طيب ولكن سعيد
السيارات لم يلاقي تجاوبا لا بل على العكس
لقى الانتقادات داخل اوروبا وخصوصا من
الرئيس الاوكراني الذي يعتبر ان الان
لم يتبقى لديه الكثير من الوقت انا اشكرك
جزيلا شكرا على وجودك معي في نشره الرابعه
من باريس الكاتب السياسي اندريما هو شكرا
جزيلا لك
اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه دخول الفوج
الثاني من الصواريخ البالستيه العبريه
للقارات افنجرز الخدمه القتاليه وقالت
الوزاره في بيان لها ان الفوج الجديد دخل
الخدمه القتاليه في مقاطعه
اريبورج وستعزز بشكل فعال قوه الصواريخ
الاستراتيجيه الروسيه وستوسع من قدرتها
القتاليه وعرضت الوزاره مقطع فيديو لتحميل
هذه الصواريخ في صومعه تحت الارض باستخدام
وحده نقل وتحميل
اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ضربات
الصاروخيه والجويه التي شنتا امس عطلت نقل
اسلحه غربيه لمناطق القتال لدعم القوات
الاوكرانيه وحققت هدفه وقال المتحدث باسم
الوزاره اجور
كوناشينكو ان ضربات استهدفت انظمه قياده
عسكريه والمجمع الصناعي الدفاعي محطات
لطاقه في اوكرانيا واعلن ايضا عن تدمير
اربع رادارات اوكرانيه من طراز اس 300
واسقطي ثلاثه صواريخ من طرازي هيمارس
هذا وتستعد اوكرانيا لصد هجوم روسي محتمل
على العاصمه كيف يرجح العسكريون
الاوكرانيون ان يتزامن مع ذكرى الاولى
للعمليه العسكريه الروسيه في فبراير فيما
يرى الجيش الاوكراني ان الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين قد يامر في نهايه المطاف
ملايين الجنود بالانخراط في الحرب في
مواجهه مقاومه الاوكرانيه واكد قائد
العمليات الجنوبيه الاوكرانيه
همم
القوه المسلحه ستكون جاهزه لكنها ستحتاجه
الى المزيد من الدعم من الحلفاء الغربي
وستستعد السيطره على جميع اراضيها بما في
ذلك شبه جزيره القرم
تغرق وخير كيف ثاني اكبر مدن اوكرانيا في
الظلام بعد ان دمرت ضربات الروسيه الجديده
البنيه التحتيه للطاقه في جميع انحاء
البلاد
[موسيقى]
ذكرت وسائل الاعلام ايرانيه ان السلطات
اعتقلت محامي يصيح في عيني بعد كشفهما
قضيه وفاه الشاب امين وقالت صحيفه مهان
الايرانيه ان المحامي يدعى محمد علي وتم
اعتقاله مع مجموعه اخرى
بينما يؤكد زملائه انه لم يتلقى اي
استدعاءات ومحتجز دون اي شكل قانوني ولا
يزال سبب اعتقاله مجهولا
بدا عماله قطاع النفط في الاهواز جنوب غرب
ايران اضرابا عن العمل وتجمع مئات العمال
امام شركه الوطنيه الايرانيه لنفط مرددين
هتافات مردده بنظام ياتي ذلك استجابه
لدعوات العصيان المدني والتمهيد لاحتجاجات
جديده بدايه من الاثنين المقبل في مختلف
مدن ايران
[تصفيق]
اذن تستمر الاحتجاجات في ايران بزخم اكبر
من خلال المظاهرات الليليه والعصيان
المدني والاضراب عن العمل الذي
سامي لا قطاعات واسعه ابرزها النفط في وقت
تنتشر فيه دعوات للتظاهر ايام التاسعه عشر
والعشرين والحادي والعشرين من الشهر
الجهري
[موسيقى]
سدد دبلوماسيه الاوروبيه رفيع المستوى على
انه لا يوجد اي يداع للعوده الى فين في
المفاوضات النوويه مع ايران وقال في
تصريحات للعربيه ان هذه المفاوضات انتهت
بالفعل وتوقفت المحادثات بين ايران والدول
الغربيه دون التوصل لنتيجه بعد اصرار
ايران على اغلاق تحقيق تقوده لوكاله
الدوليه للطاقه الذريه قبل الحصول على
اجوبه مقبوله بشان العثور على اثار
يورانيوم في ثلاثه مواقع سريه
وصلت الى ميناء زيد في محافظه عدن اليمنيه
اليوم دفعه الثانيه من منحه المشتقات
النفطيه السعوديه بكميات بلغت اربعين الف
طن المتري من ماده الديزل و30 الف طوني
مترين من ماده المازوت وذلك امتداد لدعم
السعوديه المستمر للشعب اليمني واستجابه
لطلب الحكومه اليمنيه لمساعدتها في توفير
المشتقات النفطيه لتشغيل اكثر من 70 محطه
لتوليد الكهرباء في انحاء اليمن
عبرت الولايات او الامم المتحده عن قلقها
تجاه سياسات تويتر على الرغم من رفع الحظر
على حسابات صحفيين مرحبا المفوض السامي
لحقوق الانسان
على تويتر الا انه عاد وحده من ان هناك
مخاوف جديه تجاه السياسات الخاصه بتويتر
محملا في الوقت ذاته من السماء حقوق
الانسان
هذا وكان له الناس اعلن اعاده حسابات
العديد من الصحفيين الذين تم حضرهم على
منصه التواصل الاجتماعي وكان الاتحاد
الاوروبي هدد بفرض عقوبات على ماسك فيما
اعتبرته الامم المتحده قراره تعليق
الحسابات سابقه خطيره
قرار حظر حسابات عدد من الصحفيين على
تويتر لم يمر مرور الكرام
انتقادات وضغوط دوليه اضافه الى تهديدات
من الاتحاد الاوروبي بفرض عقوبات على
الرئيس التنفيذي لمنصه الطائر الازرق
الماسك غيرت بوصله قراره اذ اعلن ماسك انه
سيعيد حسابات العديد من الصحفيين الذين تم
حظرهم على المنصه مؤخرا لكن قبل الاعلان
كان ماسك قد اطلق استطلاعا على المنصه حول
ما اذا كان سيتم استعاده حسابات الصحفيين
اكثر من 58% من الاصوات ايدت استعادتها
على الفور لكن مصر لم يفعلها فورا انتهاء
التصويت
قرارات ماسك على تويتر مفعولها كبير
وتاثيرها السلبي اكبر خصوصا عليه حيث
تراجعت اسهم شركه تسلا بنسبه اكثر من
اربعه في المئه وسجلت اسوا خساره
الاسبوعيه لها منذ مارس 2020 مع تزايد قلق
المستثمرين
رئيسه قسم الثقه والامان في تويتر اكدت ان
فريق المنصه راجع يدويا جميع الحسابات
التي تنتهك سياسه الخصوصيه الجديده موضحه
ان السياسه الجديده شملت حسابات غير
الصحفيين فيما كشف الجمعيات حقوقيه ان
تصرفات تويتر الاخيره تنتهيكم مبدا ان من
الصوت وسائل التواصل الاجتماعيه ستسمح
بالتوزيع غير المصفى للمعلومات الموجوده
بالفعل
عواصف لا تبشر بالنهايه القريبه يتخبط بها
عملاق التواصل الاجتماعي تويتر
رياحها قرارات ربما تكون عشوائيه لكنها
جعلت من الرؤيه على المدى البعيد ضبابيه
رابع مستمره وفيها بعد قليل ايضا الداخليه
السعوديه تضبط 24 متورطا في نقل واي
وتشغيل مخالف انظمه الاقامه والعمل خلال
اسبوع
[موسيقى]
حياكم الله من جديد
في عام 2020 سجل نظام العمل المرن المطبق
من قبل وزاره الموارد البشريه توثيق اكثر
من 225,000 فقط يتضمن التوثيق مشاهدينا
توضيحا لضوابط العمل المحدد المده
والساعات ويشهد النظام اقبالا من قبل
الشركات والباحثين عن العمل مراسل العربيه
التقى باحد الاشخاص والشركات التي
تستفيدوا من هذا النظام
تنقل عبد الله بين سبع جهات في فتره وجيزه
في سبع قطاعات مختلفه
وبساعاتي عمل مارينا مستفيدا من نظام
العمل المرن الذي يتيح فرصا وظيفيا بساعات
مسجلا اكثر من 200 و 225,000 عقد مرن منذ
تطبيق النظام قبل سنتين
اشبه برحله ااه ما قبل الدخول في سوق
العمل اااه تنقلت بين بين ضيعتها يعني
شركه اخرى عملت اقل ساعه هي ثلاث ساعات
عملتها خلال اسبوع اعلى ساعه حققتها هي
قرابه همم 40 ساعه في الاسبوع محمد سار
على اقتناس الفرصه بعد تطبيق النظام
فاسسه منصه تجمع اصحاب الشركات والباحثين
عن عمل في نمط العمل
ساهمت شركته بتوفير 40,000 فرصه وظيفيه
خلال فتره وجيزه والله الحمد في المنصه
عندنا لدينا اكثر من 380,000 مسجل من خلال
منصه يبحثون عن همم فرص وظيفيه من 70
مدينه حول المملكه نحن موجودين في اكثر من
25 مدينه اليوم نعمل فيها بشكل مستمر
ونغطي همم احتياجات عمنا اكثر المستفيدين
من النظام هم النساء
اللاتي وجدنا في هذا النظام فرصه الاختيار
وظيفه بالساعات والايام التي تناسبهم و
بنسبه وصلت ل 50% من العاملين في هذا
النمط بالاضافه الى الطلبه والموظفين
الباحثين عن زياده دخلهم الشهري
عبد المحسن الحربي العربيه الرياض من جده
خبيره الموارد البشريه الدكتوره دعاء ميرا
دكتوره مرحبا بك
بدايه التطبيقات
منذ بدايه تطبيق نظام العمل في الموارد
البشريه كيف تقيمينه اولا
طبعا المبادره هي احد المبادرات اللي يشكر
عليها وزاره الموارد البشريه
لانها تحقيق كثير من الاهداف وكثير من
الامور اللي كان يحجز عنها صاحب العمل او
الباحث عن عمل من خلال العمل التقليدي
جميعنا اعتدنا عليه اولا خلينا نعرف ااا
ايش تعريف العمل طبعا العمل المرن كما ذكر
في التقرير انه هو العمل الذي يخوف صاحب
العمل والباحث عن العمل بالتعاقد بشكل مرن
اا ويحسب الاجر على اساس السعاده او العمل
المنجز خلال ساعات هذه طبعا الجميل في هذا
النظام انه صاحب العمل له كثير من الفوائد
اللي حصل عليها مثل هذا النظام وايضا
الباحث عن العمل
مش صاحب العمل
الباحه عن العمل اول شيء طبعا اول فائده
بالنسبه له وهو يستفيد من نظام التامينات
الاجتماعيه بالرغم انه هو ما هو همم عقد
دوام كامل لكن يستطيع ان يستفيد من
التامينات الاجتماعيه اذا حقق بعض الشروط
ومنها ان هو يكمل 180 68 ساعه في منشاه
واحده او عده منشات وفي كثير من الشروط
الاخرى الامر الاخر طبعا همم يحقق التوازن
في بعض الفئات من المجتمع لا يستطيع ان
يحقق التوازن في ظل عمل همم بدوام كامل
ايضا له الاحقيا ويعمل على كذا مشروع على
عقد عمل مرن همم مع مختلف الشركات او
المنشات يستطيع ان يختار صاحب العمل بشكل
كبير طبعا عندنا فئه ال ال الطلاب وفئه
ذوي الاحتياجات الخاصه او فئه النساء هم
اكثر المستفيدين من هذا النظام والمبادره
القائمه همم
225,000 عقد تم طريقه عبر منصه نظام العمل
المرن واسال هنا هل اولا هذا الرقم هو همم
رقم همم كبير او على الاقل رقم متوقع
وايضا هل تتوقعين انه حيصير في اقبال
وانتشار اكبر همم هذا النوع من العمل
العمل المرن بساعه محدده بايام محدده كل
شيء محدد فيه نعم
نعم
وزاره العمل وكثير من الوزارات بجهود
مشتركه كان فيها دراسه بتحلل الاحتياجات
الخاصه بالعمل عن بعد العمل العمل وما الى
ذلك فكان تتوقع رقم همم 20 همم
تقريبا 230,000 عقد والان الرقم اتعدى هذا
الرقم الى 225,000 والان في دراسه الاخيره
15 11 20 وصل 72,000 عقد عمل همم
طبعا المتوقع همم في هذه الدراسه انه يصل
الى 300,000 عقد عمل بحلول 20 همم
احنا عندنا النظام
تقصد انه هيكون في اقبال الكبيره على هذا
نوع من العمل طيب احنا عندنا نظام العمل
وعندنا ايضا نظام اخر اللي هو نظام العمل
الحر اسال هنا عن اي تقاطعات قد تحصل بين
النظامين
يعني باحد النساء الخبيرات فيما يخص موارد
الموارد ال- ال- البشريه وهل تتعارض اصلا
مع بعضها البعض هذين النظامين خلينا خلينا
نفرق نحنا عرفنا ايش هو العمل عن العمل
عن طريق الساعات هذا بالنسبه للعمل للمريض
طيب العمل الحر العمل الحر والشخص يشتغل
لحساب الخاص ولا يشترط في عدد ساعات وانما
يصدر فيه بانجاز مهمه او مشروع معين او
تقرير معين ولا يلتزم فيه عقد عمل فهذا
الفرق بين العقد ال- ال- العمل الحر او
عفوا العمل الحر والعمل طيب ايش التقاطعات
التقاطع بكثير من الاشياء اول شيء طبعا لا
يتطلب من الشخص الذي يعمل في هذا النظام
بخبره او بفتره تجريبيه همم يستطيع يعمل
على كده مشروع في نفس الوقت يستطيع عنده
حريه في اختيار الهمم المنشاه طبعا جميع
هذه الانظمه همم طبعا لا يتطلب من صاحب
المنشاه ان هو يعوضه باجازات مدفوعه او
بنهايه خدمه او تامين طبي همم كمان هذه
يعني يطيح للشخص التوازن زي ما ذكرنا انه
جميعها تحقق هذا الامر ولكن الطبيعه
التعاقد مختلفه هذا هو الفرق بين الاثنين
لكن
تتقاطع في عمليه همم حريه الاختيار همم لا
يتطلب فتره تجريبيه ولا يتطلب صاحب العمل
ببعض النفقات التشجينيه الاخرى انا اشكرك
جزيل الشكر على وجودك معي في نشره الرابعه
من جده خبيره موارد البشريه الدكتوره دعاء
عامر شكرا لك دكتوره يعطيكم العافيه شكرا
خلال اسبوع ضبطت وزاره الداخليه السعوديه
نحو اربعه عشر الف مخالف لانظمه العمل
وامن الحدود بالاضافه الى نظام الاقامه
والذي سجل وحده اكثر من 8000 مخالف لي
يشكل العدد الاكبر بين مخالفي الانظمه
الداخليه ضبطت ايضا اربعه وعشرين متورطا
في نقل وتشغيل مخالفي الانظمه اعلانات في
بيانها ترحيل اكثر من 11 الف مخالفا خلال
الفتره نفسها
في عام 2019 بدات نسمه المولى رحلتها مع
محاربه سرطان اللوكيميا الذي اصابه ابنها
من خلال حسابي على تويتر اصعب اوقات تلك
التجربه قبل ان تؤسس المجتمع نسمه الذي
يعمل على توفير الدعم وتقديم الانشطه
المتنوعه للامهات لتخفيف عنهن ومساعدتهن
في مواجهه الضغوطات النفسيه تقرير التالي
يروي حكايه المجتمع نسمه لدعم امهات ابطال
السرطان
[موسيقى]
انا نسمه المله اقوم لثلاثه اطفال
ومحاربه مع ابن البطل فارس ضد اللوكيمياء
فكره التثقيف الصحي
للعامه بدات انه انا كان حسابي خاص
حساباتي كلها كانت خاصه انستقرام وسناب
شات بدات في سناب باصور في المستشفى وكنت
كل يوم اكتب يوميات فارس مع العلاج من
بدايه التشخيص فبدا معرفه هو صاحباتي
يقولوا لي طيب
في ناس كثير ما يعرف المعلومات
[موسيقى]
فكرت في الموضوع وقتك كنت في الثانويه
فكره اللقاء بس كنت مشغوله في علاج فارس
فالحمد لله خلص علاجه الان وقدرت اتفرغ
الافكار اللي كانت في بالي من اول من
ضمنها فكره لقاء الامهات
والفكره منه انه مشاركه مجتمعيه عشان في
يعني يوفر الامهات ليه اجاذبه تحس نفسيتهم
[موسيقى]
تقدر
اليوم حيكون معانا في اللقاء كوتش تقدم
لنا جلسه يوجا وتعطينا نصائح للتعامل مع
الضغوطات اعتقد انه كل يوم محتاجه يعني
الامهات عموما وخصوصا وامهات ابطال
السردينه
اه انصح الامهات الجدد
امهات ابطال البكيني انهم او امهات
السرطان عموم يعني انها تحاول تحافظ على
هدوئها وقدام الطفل خصوصا لانه هو يستمد
قوته مني او من امه في كل ما يشوفك قويه
وصامدا يعرف ان الامور تحت السيطره فهو
يطمن فهي دي الفكره الاساسيه في دور الام
او الاهل عموما مع اطفالهم
[موسيقى]
اليوم في جده فعاليات معرض الكتاب التي
استمرت لمده 10 ايام حيث شارك في هذه
النسخه اكثر من 900 دينار نشر محليه
وعربيه ودوليه وجمل البرنامج الثقفي
للزوار مشاركه واسعه من المثقفين والكتاب
والفنانين ومن المقرر ان تحتضن المنطقه
الشرقيه معرض الكتاب
القادم خلال الاشهر المقبله بتنظيم من
هيئه الادب والنشر والترجمات السعودي
المعرض جده الدولي للكتاب ينضم الينا
مراسل العربيه عبد الواحد الحميد عبد
الواحد مساء الخير مرحبا بك معي في نشره
الرابعه من الرياض
طبعا في اليوم الاول من افتتاح المعرض
اليوم اختتم هذا المعرض عبد الواحد
ابرز ما رصدته خلال رحله معرض الكتاب في
جده هذا الموسم
نعم نايف اهلا وسهلا بك طبعا ما يميز هذه
النسخه من معرض جدا للكتاب انها طبعا اتت
بعد ثلاث سنوات من القطاع اولا وثانيا
البرنامج الثقافي الذي كان متنوعا لدرجه
انه كان يحتوي جلسات متعلقه بالانمي
وصناعه الافلام وحتى موضوعات مختلفه يعني
لم نعتد مشاهدتها في معارض الكتب في
السعوديه
الاهم ان هذه الايام العشره التي يعني مرت
سريعا في معرض جدا للكتاب شهيده اقبالا
كبيرا من الناس يعني نحن نتحدث ان في بعض
الايام تحديدا الايام الاخيره في اوقات
الذروه لم يستطع البعض الوصول الى معرض
الكتاب بسبب الازدحام الشديد همم يعني في
مواقف السيارات وفي مداخل خارج سوبر دوم
المكان الذي يحتضن هذا المعرض نحن الان في
الساعات الاخيره من معرض جده للكتاب كما
تشاهد هناك اقبال كبير من الناس ل- همم
يعني همم المتابعه المستمره والاستغلال
الساعات الاخيره من هذا المعرض الذي يحتوي
العديد من الفعاليات وحتى الجلسات
والندوات الثقافيه والممسيات الشعريه
وغيرها من الموضوعات التي تم طرحها هنا في
معرض جده للكتاب كما تشاهد نايف يعني دور
النشر في الايام الاخيره عاده تستغل هذه
الفرصه وحتى بعض النشر كانت تقدم خصومات
وتنزل في الاسعار قليلا كما ان المكتبات
تشتري من بعضها البعض لان كما تعلم هناك
مشاركات من دول مختلفه همم وفيما يتعلق
بعمليه البيع والشراء هذه النسخه كذلك
كانت يعني النسخه التي لم تشهد البيع
بالكاش وهذه ضمن الاشتراطات التي وضعتها
هيئه الادب والنشر همم والترجمه
يعني هذه النسخه ولهذا العام تحديدا ااه
اخيرا نايف فيما يتعلق بالضيوف كان كانت
هناك اسماء كبيره من المقرر ان ان تحضر
الى يعني هذا المعرض لانه كما تعلم كانت
هناك مناطق خاصه بالخيال العلمي فكان احد
اهم هذه الاسماء تشيروا اودا وهو مؤلف
سلسله همم وان بيس الانمي الياباني الشهير
من اللي بدا من 96 ال- ال- الشخصيه
الشهيره هذه يعني جعلت العديد من الناس
ياتون الى جده من من خارج المملكه ومن مدن
مختلفه كذلك لحضور هذه الجلسه والتي يعني
اعلنت اداره المعرض بان همم الضيف اعتذر
عن حضور هذه الجلسه لكن همم يعني الاقسام
الاخرى مستمره يعني وكذلك الاقسام
المتعلقه حتى بالرسومات المانجا وهمم يعني
حتى الخيال العلمي موجوده ويعني تشهد
اقبال كبير من نايف ونحن نعتذر منك لضيق
الوقت عبد الواحد شكرا جزيلا لك من معرض
جده الدولي للكتاب ضميرينا مراسل العربيه
عبد الواحد الحميد
رابع مستمره تتابعونا فيها بعد قليل
محميه اليوم تطلق اربعه انواع من
الحيوانات البريه من بينها المها العربي
والغزال الجبلي
حياكم الله من جديد في السعوديه تنطلق
اليوم اولى بطولات الفروسيه الكبرى للفئه
الاولى والتي افتتحت بكاسي ولي العهد
للخيل المنتجه المحليا والمستورده بجائزه
قدرها مليون ريال لكل فائز بالكاس ويشاركه
في البطوله السعوديه العالميه بنسختها 57
اكثر من 30 جوازات لقطع مسافه تمتد الى
و400 متر
من المسابقات الفروسيه ينضم الينا مراسل
العربيه عبد المحسن الحربي عبد المحسن
مساء الخير مرحبا بك معي في نشره الرابعه
من الرياض انقلي الاجواء كيف تبدو الاشواط
ايضا كذلك التي ستكون حظيره اليوم في هذه
المسابقات
اليوم بدات المسابقات بهذه الاشواط الاحد
عشر والتي انطلقت قبل ثلاثه ساعات من الان
الان نحن في الشوط ربما الثالث او حتى
ندخل الى الشوط الرابع اما الاشواط
المرتقبه والتي الانظار كلها عليها هي
الشوطين الاخرين لكي سي ولي العهد للانتاج
والمستورد حيث هنالك مشاركه كبيره جدا من
ملاك وايضا من همم متسابقين في كافه هذه
همم المنافسات التي ستنطلق اليوم
برعايه ولي العهد السعودي بجوائز كبرى
نتحدث عن مليونين ريال سعودي لكل جائزه
مليون وهمم وتحدث مع متخصصين نايف في
الفروسيه قالوا بان هذه الجائزه ارتفعت
خلال الفتره الاخيره بشكل كبير جدا هناك
اهتمام ايضا كبير جدا ما دفع الى جوده
المنافسه ان ترتفع بشكل عام لضع في الصوره
حيث همم هذه الاجواء الرائعه في ميدان
الملك عبد العزيز الذي ستقام عليه هذه
وتقام حاليا الشوط الان سندخل الى الشوط
الرابع وبعده الخامس هذه المنافسات حضور
مختلف عائلي همم وايضا لمواطنين ومقيمين
يستمتعون بهذه الاجواء بشكل عام في انتظار
المسابقه الكبيره التي ستنطلق عند الساعه
7:30
ولي العهد الانتاج
والمستورد طبعا هنالك تحدث عن المرشحين
لهتين همم المسابقتين هنالك عدد كبير من
المرشحين هذا هذا هذا الموضوع يعني انا
سالت المتخصصين في هذا
المجال قالوا بانه ليس همم مبالغه ان همم
كل المرشحين في هذه همم او كل المتسابقين
في هاتين المسابقتين هم مرشحين
عن ربما ال- همم الفائز في السنه الماضيه
لهلان ولاجام لملاكمه الامير سعود بن
سلمان ايضا هنالك منافسه شرسه لمديه همم
خيول اخرى نتحدث عن اخو باري وراسمالي
لفيصل بن خالد الامير فيصل بن خالد
كلهاتين كلها اوائل الجياد وايضا
المتسابقين ينتظرون بشغف هذه
الشوطين او هذين الشوطين الذين سيبدان بعد
ساعه 7:30 بشكل عام نايف فروسيه ما يخص
المسابقه في ما يخص الجهاد المشاركه فيما
يخص المرشحين لكن خليني اسال كذلك عن
الجمهور الحضور الى هذه المسابقه يعني همم
من المعروف ان الفروسيه يعني مسابقات
الفروسيه لحظه بجماهيريه كبيره في
السعوديه لكن همم رفع مستوى المسابقات
الجوائز ايضا كذلك رفع معه الحضور
الجماهيري الى هذه المسابقه عبد المحسن من
خلال وجودك وردك
نعم ربما خلال الايام الماضيه نايف شاهد
عدد كبير جدا لاشخاص يريدون الحضور
للاستمتاع وايضا اشخاص دخلوا في عمق هذه
المنافسه واصبحوا يبحثون عن من الفائز
وتولى لكل لهذا ال- ميدان بكل حماس
ليترقبوا من الفائز فبالتالي هنالك انتشار
واسع وكبير جدا لكل الحضور
للمشاركين او حتى الحضور الذين يستمعون به
الاجواء بشكل عام لترقب من الفائز وهذا
ربما لا يعكس الاهتمام الكبير الذي حصل
لهذه الرياضه تحديدا خلال الاربع سنوات
الماضيه نقلت هذه الرياضه نقله كبيره جدا
الجوائز ارتفعت بشكل كبير جدا
ايضا عن كاس السعوديه الذي همم هؤلاء
المشاركين الفائزين ربما بهذين الشوطين
همم يريدان يريدون بان يكون تصريفهم عالي
جدا ليشاركه بهذه المسابقه الدوليه
العالميه التي تتخطى جوائزها ال20 مليار
دولار وبالمناسبه هذه المسابقه كاس
السعوديه رفع التصنيف هذا الميدان الى همم
مستويات متقدمه وجعلته من الميادين
العالميه التي تجرى عليها
المسابقات الدوليه واربما هناك اهتمام
كبير جدا ايضا حتى باذن الله جعلهم يشترون
جياد وايضا
ياتون بالتعزيزات لديهم لدى الاستبلاتهم
للفوز بالمسابقات والمشاركه بمسابقات
الدوليه التي
تقام هنا في السعوديه ضعيف
التفاصيل من ميدان الملك عبد العزيز
الفروسيه ورثه العربيه عبد المحسن الحربي
شكرا جزيلا لك
الموجز الرياضي مع زميله ليليان تنوري
اليك ليليا
[موسيقى]
اهلا بك اخبرنا عن الاجواء قبل حوالي
الساعه او ب او ساعه او اكثر مباراه
[موسيقى]
نحن الان نبث من المسار الخاص او المؤدي
الى استاد خليفه اريد ان انقل لك المشهد
هنا ليليان لاحظي امامك همم جماهير مغربيه
وجماهير من قياس من جنسيات مختلفه همم
هواتفهم هؤلاء الاشخاص طيله الايام اللي
فاتت حاولوا والحصول على التذاكر ولكن لم
يتمكنوا وهذه هي المنطقه الاخيره التي
يمكننا من الوصول لها من دون تذاكر لذلك
نحن نشهد الان يعني مفاوضات في ما يخص
موضوع التذاكر ومبيعات التذاكر وانت واقف
في هذه المنطقه ي- مؤمن امامك اشخاص
يهمسون بصوت خفيف ينتكت تبدا المفاوضات
ولا يعني كنت شاهد قبل قليل على
مفاوضات قاموا بها شبان من المغرب كيف
كانكم
مازال غير كم وصلت تصدق يعني واصله شيء
450 دولار 500 دولار
ابحث عن تيكي منذ البارحه وفي يعني في
السيت ديال الفيفا مبلوكي ما كاينش ما
كيشتيك يعني تيعطيك تيوصلك حتى لواحد
المرحله انك
بتخلصين فلما سالتهم اكتشفت انهم هم جايين
هنا عشان يشترون تذاكر مباراه
بس انه الامن بدا يبعدهم فلسطين
ااا نحنا بدنا يعني نطلب ايه تذاكر
الارجنتين الفاينل لكن الاسعار انا مهوله
بالنسبه همم
شيء جنوني
حتى نوعيه الجماهير يعني مباراه الثالث
والرابع الحضور اغلبهم يعني عائلات واطفال
لو تشاهدين حاضرين للمتعه ومشترين التذاكر
من فتره طويله فقط تجربه حضور مباراه همم
مباريات المونديال طيب نايف يعني سؤال هل
هناك جنسيه غير من المغرب
وكرواتيا يعني هل هناك جنسيه اخرى كانت
قطعت كما قلت تذاكر واحتفظت بها وتريد
مشاهده المباراه يعني هناك جنسيه غير هذه
ما زالت متواجده في الدوحه
بالتاكيد همم ليليان لو لو تشاهدين شوفي
جنسيات مختلفه من مختلف ال الدول العالم
متواجده لحضور همم المباراه هناك على
الجماهير مغربيه ولكن ليست بذات العدد في
المباراه السابقه امام فرنسا ولكن كما
تشاهدين يعني جنسيات متعدده اطفال عائلات
يحضرون لهذه المباراه للمتعه طبعا هناك لو
تشاهدين تواجد الامني همم المكثف حتى يكون
هناك تدافع وتزاعهم للاشخاص الذين لا
يملكون تذاكر قامت اللجنه المنظمه بوضع
شاشتين همم في اماكن مختلفه كبيره للاشخاص
الذين لا يجدون تذاكر لكن هذه دائما
مباريات التي تشهد تواجد عدد كبير في
المناطق المحيطه من دون يكون هناك تعزيز
همم من العناصر الامن البطوله
بكثافه هذه جنسيه من الجنسيه الهنديه
الجنسيات
همم تحضر لي
حضور المباراه اليوم شكرا جزيلا لك نايف
سنكون معك طبعا ده متوسط دائما انت وزملاء
تي ولا اليوم ان شاء الله شكرا لك
افتتح في العاصمه السعوديه الرياضه النسخه
الثانيه والسبعون الموسم نادي سباقات
الخيل بكاسي ولي العهد للخيل المنتجه
محليا وللخال المستورده على ارض ميدان
الملك عبد العزيز بالجنادريه تبلغ جائزه
كل كاس مليون ريال تعد كاسات ولي العهد
اولى البطولات الكبرى للفئه الاولى وهي
تقام في الموسم الجديد بنسختها السابعه
والخامسه
نهايه اخبار رياضه شكرا لمتابعتكم اعود
اليك نايف
[موسيقى]
شكرا ليليان في السعوديه وضمن المرحله
الاولى من برنامج اعاده توطين الكائنات
الفطريه اطلقت في محميه نيوم اليوم اربعه
انواع من الحيوانات البريه هي المها
العربي والوعل وضبي الريم والغزال الجبلي
المحميه التي تمتد على 25,000 كيلو متر
مربع تهدف لتوفير النظام البيئي للحفاظ
على الطبيعه وزياده التنوع الاحيائي في
المنطقه تحقيقا لمستهدفات مبادره تكاثر
انواع الحياه البريه المهدده بالانقراض
التابعه للمركز الوطني لتنميه الحياه
الفطريه والتي تندرج تحت مظله مبادره
السعوديه الخضراء
اعلن المركز اييي مركز الارصاد الوطني في
السعوديه عن توقعاته الى حاله الطقس والتي
تضمنت باستمرار انخفاض درجه الحراره في
الرياض والمنطقه الشرقيه الارصاد السعوديه
افادت ايضا توقعاتها باستمرار هطول
الامطار على مكه واجسامنا منطقه جنوبيه
منها جازان وعسير
هذا تذكرهم بالعناوين قبل ان نختم الرابعه
روسيا تقول بان حزمه العقوبات الجديده
ستفاقم المشكلات الاقتصاديه للاتحاد
الاوروبي
وسائل الاعلام الايرانيه تقول بان السلطات
اعتقلت صحافيين كشفاء قضيه مقتل الشاب
امين
وصوله سبعين الف طوني من الديزل والمازوت
الى عدم ضمن الدفعه الثانيه من منحه
المشتقات السعوديه
المنتخب المغربي يواجه مساء اليوم كرواتيا
في مباراته تحديد المركزين الثالث والرابع
شكرا لكم في المتابعه نهايه الرابعه الى
اللقاء
يا هلا والله وغلا يا مرحبا يا مرحبا تفضل
تفضل
[موسيقى]